edward zuckeria nearly died trying to
get an education
just a few weeks ago boko haram
insurgents attacked his school and
killed several guards
edward now goes to school in the nearby
town of yola
but still he's haunted by what happened
most especially when we hear any
unnecessary sound
around us so we have to be afraid of to
come back to our normal senses
whether to know what's happening
the islamist militant group has launched
a series of attacks on villages
in the matagali district of northeast
nigeria
in march they burned down edward's
school he and his classmates
fled into the bush
it was very very terrible because they
came
mainly for us in order to kill us but
with help of god
they couldn't get us on the compound so
most of us some even cried because they
never experienced that
like edward dozens from his old school
now have to travel to yola to get an
education
the school does what it can to help
though resources were scarce
even before the new students came
so naturally they are coming stretched
our facilities but of course we have to
absorb them they are brothers
and our students who showed a lot of
understanding to help them come out of
the trauma i think that was even the
bigger challenge
the traumatic experience they have gone
through
school enrollment is low in much of
nigeria
around yola less than 40 percent get an
elementary education
many parents keep their children home
fearing attacks
and abductions for weeks there have been
discussions in nigeria on how to improve
the security situation in schools
but so far not much has happened at this
school only one watchman is on duty at
the gate
and the headteacher told us that even
during national examinations
only one policeman is in charge of the
security of hundreds of students here
but edward and his classmates refuse to
stay home they're looking forward to the
soccer world cup
with nigeria taking part boko haram
condemned sport as well as education
as a relic of western colonialism but
edward and his friends say they won't
let their lives be
dictated by fear